welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul and huge happy birthday
to see mouli
who is likely celebrating with the first
trailer for shang chi
the movie stars him as the titular
character and he's the first
asian superhero to head up a marvel
movie sorry scarlett johansson
the trailer is incredible and throughout
this video we're going to be discussing
some of its characters
the easter eggs things you missed and
everything you need to know about it
if you enjoyed the video then please
smash the thumbs up and make sure you
subscribe for content like this each and
every day
we are currently covering falcon in the
winter soldier and you definitely don't
want to miss our breakdown on the finale
coming this friday
so make sure you get it locked in yeah
now without the way
thank you for clicking this now let's
get into our breakdown of
shanxi and the legend of the ten rings
okay so the ten rings are an
organization that you will likely
remember from the first iron man movie
the terrorist organization was hired by
obadiah stein to kidnap tony stark
and he pretty much put him on the path
to become iron man iron man 3 starred
guy pierce's aldrich killian
who was posing as their lead of the
mandarin and the marvel one shot that
accompanied that film showed the actor
trevor being confronted by one of their
members in prison
kylian taking on the moniker caused a
lot of controversy
and kevin feige has stated that they are
writing that wrong by having the real
mandarin appearing in this film
yay now the movie itself is apparently
going to show the criminal empire that
he has amassed over the years
this film is actually set to show events
that happen between the snap in the blip
as well as the aftermath of it bringing
us fully up to speed with the mcu
if you cast your mind back to end game
you'll remember that there was a big bit
with hawkeye in which he was taking down
mobsters in tokyo
this arc is apparently going to be
expanded on and we will follow certain
members of the 10 rings as they seize
power
during the collapse of society though we
might not see things from hawkeye's
perspective
we could see these mobsters potentially
popping up in the movie
explaining certain parts in endgame it's
all connected
now as for the mandarin the film is
gonna be making him not only the leader
of the ten rings
but also the father of shanxi this
differs quite a lot from the comic books
as in those it was fu manchu who was his
dad
however marvel came out and said that
because he played on a lot of
stereotypes that
he's a bit of a problematic character
and thus they've decided to combine both
the mandarin and thu manchu
into well the mandarin now this is
something similar to what they did with
whiplash
who was a combination of crimson dynamo
and
well whiplash now there's there's
actually a big article on wikipedia that
talks about the controversy that
fumanchi was caused over the years
such as his nonsensical name the fact
he's basically just a stereotype
and also that he said in a book once
kill the white man and take his woman
so yeah just avoid all that if you can
yeah i'm quite happily married with my
wife now played by tony luang
director destin daniel [ __ ] has said
that they want to smash asian
stereotypes
and that the mandarin will be the
character to do this so yeah fu manchu
is about as popular as army hammer is at
a vegan meetup
and thus in my opinion they've
definitely done the right thing
as for shang chi in the mcu he's been
trained by his
father in the ways of martial arts since
he was a child and the character has
very much seen the ins and outs of the
criminal organization
in the source material they never out
and out said what his powers and
abilities are
and depending on what you read very much
depends on what version you get
though he has possessed superhuman
abilities from time to time
on the whole shang chi tends to just be
a normal person
with a very certain set of skills
because of this shang chi
is a next level athlete that's often
referred to as the greatest empty-handed
fighter in the marvel universe
move over iron fist just stupid chump
get
get the hell out of here shang chi is
master chi
and because of this he's able to push
his body beyond the usual limitations
that normal people face
he could basically do a trailer
breakdown 20 minutes after the trailer
releases
which is almost as fast as me god damn
now being able to tap into this energy
force means that he has a heightened
sense of awareness to everything around
him
i don't think i'm spoiling anything here
by saying that the film will pretty much
revolve around him going toe-to-toe with
his father
and he will likely wrestle with whether
to keep it in the family like stephen
sharon carter
or become his own man that fights for
truth and justice
spoiler alert it's probably the latter
he's also going to be joined by his
estranged sister xiao ling
who will also be the mandarin's daughter
spoiler alert again now i kind of feel
that if the mandarin gets taken down in
this film
that she might step into his shoes and
could end up becoming the villain in any
feature films
ares has said that shang chi is one of
the only people on earth that could
stand toe-to-toe with the god
and though he probably won't be facing
off against them we do know that bing
fan
boom will be in the film and that this
dragon super villain will probably cause
a lot of issues too
it's going to be interesting to see how
they pull this off but i kind of feel
that they're going to weave this in as a
challenge for shanxi to take on
in the comics however he is a big super
villain so they might even have it all
connected to the ten rings
and this could come as a big shock to
shang chi who discovers that his father
is in league with the monster
that might lead to him uncovering the
truth but again all fan theories at the
moment
the funko pops for the characters show
that he's called the great protector
so who knows he might even be a good guy
the next big character we need to
discuss is katie
who according to the wiki is shang chi's
friend
friend being in quotation marks i'm
guessing now according to interviews
she's going to be thrust into a world
where she doesn't really know what to do
and at the same time she'll be
discovering things about herself
you also have jaya lee as well as razor
fist
razor fist is a super villain that has
no superpowers
but like chiang chi he has quite a high
level of stamina and strength
after honing his body to perfection he
decided to take the next logical step
and replace his hand with a blade makes
sense now in the comics
there's been three versions of the
character with some cutting off both
hands
whilst others just did the one makes it
a nightmare when you have a girlfriend
if you do both
so this version is just gonna have the
one now there's also gonna be ronnie
chang as jon jon
and michelle yo as jayannan she's
previously featured in guardians of the
galaxy vol 2
but at the moment they are doing a lot
of things with actors playing different
people so
i guess it's just one of those things
now the trailer starts off with the
mandarin discussing how he's allowed
shanxi to have 10 years to live his life
we know that he's had a good time during
this but now he's being called back to
do his family duties
we see him as a valet and also hanging
out with some friends taking selfies you
know
just a normal life now 10 is an
important number
as he was also trained for 10 years as a
boy which we see in the first look
this training chronicles him growing up
and it's clear he was put through his
paces in order to be the best
it's here we're introduced to death
dealer as well who is one of his
father's closest allies
shang chi is definitely going to be
going head-to-head with him at several
points
as he tries to take his dad down and
expect to see some amazing fight sets
with this character now this training
was put in place so that the most
dangerous people in the world wouldn't
be able to kill him
being the son of the head of a criminal
empire obviously makes him a target
and the mandarin was likely worried that
he might be captured and used for ransom
this could explain why we see him doing
low-level jobs throughout the trailer
as they might have been put in place for
him to keep a low profile
it's here that we also get a close look
at taser face so
sorry razorfist here now it looks like
there's also going to be some
supernatural elements in the film
such as some giant beasts and sideways
water
that's that's a scientific term now the
film seems to be very steeped in the
elements
and there could be people who can
control water it seems like the mandarin
is almost the one doing
it at one point as he opens up a vault
making me think that he is perhaps the
one doing it
however that might be wrong but with so
many changes to the source material you
just don't know
now we get a closer look at the beasts
later on and i'm guessing
just in the same way that rhinos were
used in black panther that this will
happen with them and also the winged
creatures
at one point we see that the mandarin
has ten rings around his wrist
five on each side and these power up in
the trailer
there's a bit where someone is using
something similar to destroy a table
i'm guessing that this is the mandarin
possessing superhuman abilities at this
point
there's also an interesting part in
which he fights his sister
in what seems to be a tournament shang
chi was very much the favorite
and thus she's had to go off and craft
her own legend potentially taking part
in things like this
this is why i think that she will take
the mantle at some point and this fight
definitely sets up their rivalry now
speaking of razor fist
shang chi fights him on a bus at one
point and we really see how good
the martial art is gonna be in this
movie it looks incredible and i love the
fight scenes on display here
there's also a shot of ancient times
potentially showing a battle that
happened centuries ago
involving the 10 rings i might be
digging too deep but the shot we see of
the mandarin in the trailer at one point
makes him seem like he's dressed in
ancient attire the character might even
be immortal in this movie
and we could see his very first battle
happening here the 10 rings is an
organization that's existed over the
millennia
so if he lives forever then it does make
a lot of sense why he's managed to keep
control
as mentioned earlier shang chi is
someone that can take on superpowered
beings
and therefore having his dad have
certain abilities it just
just makes the stakes higher it's even
possible that the ten rings themselves
grant superhuman abilities
and this is where the legend of the ten
rings comes from to
captain obvious now they seem like a
mcguffin similar to the infinity stones
and the mandarin wearing them clearly
having advanced abilities
it all just makes sense now the trailer
ends with a bus crash scene that's very
similar to speed with
the sandra bullock s character doing the
driving
whilst shanxi busts up the bad guys it's
a great way to end it and i can't wait
to see it and i know she's not called
the sandra bullock trailer yeah i know i
know exactly who she is
anyway now as for my thoughts on the
trailer i have to say i really enjoyed
it
i like that marvel is actually starting
to really shed light on different
cultures
and if they can pull it off with black
panther i'm sure they can do it with
this too
i really want to see some cool martial
arts in this movie and it looks like it
could be something
really really special though i'm not too
well versed in the shanghai mythos
i did the reading last night and became
an expert and i'm really glad to see
what this movie is gonna do
we've got a lot of marvel stuff coming
up this year and it feels great that
after a year of delays that we're
getting all this content coming thick
and fast
really really liked it and i'd of course
love to hear your thoughts on the
trailer
if there's anything i missed let me know
if there's a character you think is
going to be bigger
let me know and if you just hated my
accent and pronunciation
then let me know as a thank you for
interacting with the video you'll be
entered into a prize through on the 30th
of april
in which we're giving away three copies
of zack snyder's justice league in 4k
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the trailer
the winners of last month's competition
are on screen right now so if that's you
then message me on twitter heavy
spoilers
and something else to watch then make
sure you check out our breakdown of
madame hydra which is going to be linked
on screen right now
the character popped up in the latest
episode of falcon in the winter soldier
so it's definitely worth watching if you
have any questions about here
that out of the way thank you for
sticking through the video i've been
paul let's see you next time
take care peace